going on the street and talking to
people is a genre that will always work
there is a lot of people that will never
do that and it's okay to not do that
that's not you
good right but hiking and literally just
[__] spewing thoughts for an hour
that's you how late did I send it to my
friends right now I recommend hiking
along with your Dustin it took me two
days to realize why reality TV worked
I'm like [__] man drock's been following
me around for the whole day I forgot
he's here I'm this is real life you're
not having to hold it and like now
you're just in a [__] stream of
conscious like the [__] I say to myself
is the best [__] I've ever made it just
never saw the day of Earth like
especially in the last since covid I
haven't been doing the filming the same
way
man there's probably a hundred things
that would have been my most viral
videos of the year that died in my head
goes around I'm just so inspired like
one I'm the best I've ever been in life
that's awesome now I'm just sharing with
the with the your team
um and I'm just like inspired and I'm
building right now good for you brother
and like my team I said it before was
just for music I remember and um I know
what we're here for and so I'm inspired
by your team because like you've built
that and they went around the room and
they we introduced ourselves and they
say how long they work here and we were
talking about how in music like if I sit
down at the record label the magazine
was there is three years
same in this in advertising or marketing
it's worse but you're doing something
different yeah I care about them exactly
it's not super complicated it's it's the
hardest thing for people but it's
actually the easiest thing and I think
look I'm very excited about you being
here
I've seen it from afar I'm a fan I want
you to win we have a lot of insights we
can really help
but but by the way it all comes back
down to what you just like you already
have the punch line in four minutes
punchline is going to be the humans we
select
on
who they are as cute people and and then
how good are they at the craft we can
audit how good they are at the craft at
scale
truth be told they probably might
literally be sitting in my company right
now or had been in this company because
we already know who they are and like
this is a very fun gig
there's like you know there's a lot of
people that would want to be on your
content team
yeah I'd want to be on your content team
I think I think what you so I think
really there's a couple things what's
different between you and I is I'm also
a practitioner of it yeah
and you'll be less at this point of it
and I have I need to get a sense of how
much you want or not want to be
knowledgeable in the platforms how they
work things that nature I don't think
it's a requirement to be me
but if I'm at a 401 class level using
College terminology you can't be in high
school you're going to need to at least
be a one-on-one preferably a 201 and I
think any person that wants to build an
audience and get their message out has
to be capable of auditing their team the
the one of the things that is absolutely
true of that is foundational to things
that work out for me is I know it so
when I'm working with them I know it
that matters because if you don't know
it then you're in trouble right that's
why people get their money stolen from
them because they don't know finances
it's why people don't get the results
they're looking for in something because
they don't know it it's why people get
hosed by lawyers because they don't know
it it's like it's life so you're on a
mission to get this out you know
especially when you come from a music
framework and you've had some real hits
you know what it feels like to have
something you wanted people to know hit
scale you've tasted that which is rare
most people on Earth will never feel
that feeling you're right so you're
gonna you know what you're up to you
know what you want to accomplish
the content version of that
look there's viral videos no different
than having a hit song right it happens
but the reality is back to making the
comp and music the real careers there's
a lot more there than just right and so
that's what you're going to build with
this there may be things that pop off
you already have a big fan base to begin
with you have a nest at this point
because we're not 18 anymore you've been
you have even something probably more
powerful than you realize even this is
something that I'm really excited about
um
The Nostalgia aspect is real
like you know like what you know the
fact that we can re you can recall
moments where people first discovered
you is going to be very valuable so I'm
thinking a lot about that but this is
Brick by Brick and it's going to come to
making a team and then deciding very
simply how are you gonna make the
content and so what I what do I mean by
that the way I make content is happening
right now I
just record my real life there's the
concept of coming up with a couple of
consistent themes that you're going to
do
um events that you record and pretty
like you're going to need that kind of
anchor to get the post-production from
so I think that's a big big part to
think through but the biggest thing that
will be the variable of difference here
is you not lying to yourself all the
things that we're frustrated about with
my content is because I'm incapable of
doing it I'm just too busy I can't do it
like we know on my team that if I
brought back tea with garyvee like I did
during covid we'd be crushing the world
I if I woke up every morning it did
eight to nine a.m on t with garyvee we'd
have no problems on my team we would
have four to five Clips every [__]
day that are worthwhile to break down
into post-produce and we'd be [__]
moonwalking
on the flip side when I'm deeply
operational with be friends and vaynerx
and like they're like they're the first
people that don't even get two minutes
to run in and capture some content and
that gets hard so the recommendation I'm
get why did I tell you that story the
number one mistake that the MP in this
scenario always makes is they lie to
themselves about what that's your
initials
um that the the person that's making
this decision someone famous someone to
come just what I want to do like the
mistake especially when they've already
had success kids know they have time
they won't do anything right I want to
be famous I want to be a tick talker
it's when you are a grown-up and have a
real life and have had a career and
you've got your Cadence and what have
you it's you need to be real with
yourself you know for example going on
the street and talking to people is a
genre that will always work
there is a lot of people that will never
do that and it's okay to not do that
that's not you
good right but you [__] like like
hiking and literally just [__]
spewing thoughts for an hour that's you
Hallelujah did I send it to my friends
right now I recommend hiking along with
your Dustin
because what that does what you know
I'll tell you when I first started doing
the thing that became the thing like
it'll it took me two days to realize why
reality TV worked I'm like [__] man
drock's been following me around for the
whole day I forgot he's here I'm this is
real life
yeah and so like what that does is it
like you're not think about the
difference you're not having to hold it
and like now you're just in a [__]
stream of conscious like the [__] I say
to myself is the best [__] I've ever
made right it just never saw the day of
Earth
like especially in the last since covet
I haven't been doing the filming the
same way
man there's probably a hundred things
that would have been my most viral
videos of the year that died in my head
because nobody was around
that didn't happen for five years which
is why I was able to build what I built
yeah so I think you've gotta find the
team we know we this what I'm doing
right now is setting the strategy
because this team could show you
everything when they take over this
meeting and then we'll do it again like
Hannah said yesterday on email like this
is not a one and done thing like we're
here for you we'll help you through this
whole thing the biggest thing you need
to do is not lie to yourself about what
you're willing to do or not do
but challenge yourself on things you may
want to try yeah let me respond please
you said you want to get a sense of how
much I want to learn I have unlimited
time for the things that I care about I
understand that I care about my mission
my father used to say there's two ages
in life health and happiness my mission
is to make people healthier and happier
I love it I have a lot of love inside me
and what's frustrating to me is I'm not
giving all that I can I get it I know
that and you know that so I am totally
willing to learn love it yeah the
learning is easy and not lying to myself
is very easy for me good I have a I have
a very strong internal so what do you so
great let's just let's go to the next
level then I I because I buy all that
watching you from afar and knowing a
little bit about you
um
what do you think your pillars are going
to be like cool
like I let you rent the best team in the
world tomorrow what are you doing you
think like talk the pillars of like
content oh of the content I think the
number two option which is the the
podcast you want to do a podcast yeah
good that's good documented got it
um how often how often do you think you
want to do it
what's Your Gut tell you my gut tells me
to start off with a commitment at least
once a week love at least that's a
monster that's a back to you backing up
your words that's the right answer yeah
next where do you want to do it
I want to do it in LA great makes it
easy for people I have a few I have a
few uh locations I've already been
scouting
yeah like where like I mean studios are
like setups you want to do yes
do you have a sense of where there's a
play I live in Topanga Canyon yep so
it's like beautiful nature ice bass
that's my vibe I get it so there's a
place near me I can rent uh that's not
like a studio how far is that from like
people like for people that land in LAX
like how far is that 45 oh good it's
perfect okay
okay great what else if anything
content content pillows yeah pillars
I had this idea this morning it's like
where was the camera
I am someone I wake up every day and I
do like Tony Robbins incantation yeah I
want to create my own for those people
good I want to [__] like you go on my
feed and it says if you're tired listen
to this yeah and I'm guiding you if
you're angry do this if you're happy and
you want to go all the way to joyful do
this is like listen to this so I want to
create like guided content that change
people's General State and improve the
quality of their life you want to do
that in the form of so you want to go
about that more like doing an album like
actually make this is always the cool
[__]
when I tell you this [__] scares the
living [__] out of my soul I respect
these dudes the most
when I tell you this like yeah I'm like
I can feel it in my stomach right now
and I'm not even on the plucking
platform
I've gotten better with Heights overall
net net but like that shit's just crazy
we're [__] up here
um I get it though one of the other
things that's like that is public
speaking when I tell you Dustin you've
seen this a bunch when I'm backstage and
they're like eight seconds like 15
seconds and I'm like still like texting
Sid like post it now or like completely
chilling people are like what the [__]
cause for a lot of people that's the
scariest thing right you know anyway so
you want to go yeah public speaking
scares the [__] it's the one thing that
I think I do the best for me
that I know is really hard for others
and it's that I'm leaning like I'm like
one minute in front of 20 000 people I'm
not even thinking about it yeah I'm like
pure improv I'm like man it's like
walking out of this room that's awesome
um so you want to do that more
structured like instead of making the
content day-to-day be what that
represents you want to go which I fully
understand you want to go about it and
record that that's fine you'll bang it
those are I can bang out like those of
course you can do that audio to your
phone yes and then have a team and then
have a team produce post yes okay what
else if anything
so
um
I also provide experience to like
companies and teams I go like I just did
my TED Talk at Ted countdown crushed it
um so like I'll go to corporate
corporations or to professional sports
teams in San Francisco 49ers I'm a
certified Wim Hof instructor so I'll go
do 10 minutes Inspire them keynote so do
you do you want to rev up your public
speaking career yeah Zach and Steven are
coming
amazing yeah I just crushed a 10
times you document
Ed currently that film that stuff is
someone filming there's yeah yeah
um
before I bounce what about music where
is that sit in the world it's it's like
the soil from which everything sprouts
and it like I'll never stop doing it and
I'm the most creative I've ever been
would you do a daily Vlog like I did
like literally film yourself all day and
then put something else on YouTube if we
had a dope guy that I liked that didn't
annoy me like him yeah keep up with me
that is a piece of cake I mean it's not
meaning
I've had plenty of dope guys and gals
that I didn't want to work with but
plenty that I have and I feel like when
you have a lot of love inside you can
your filter is not as hard as you think
on that and we surely know what he or
she looks like
so we can help on that too let me be
true in Integrity yeah that to me is
like
let me see how it goes good news you do
one it's like anything else before you
jumped into a cold bath you had to do it
the first time
you you clearly had a you know you might
have thought it was going to be awesome
but you still had to let me see how this
goes right same same with this you do it
for a day or a week nothing longer
well I'd like you to do it forever if
you want to because it's the most
profound way it's gonna be weird for a
week you can do it for a month and you
really know if I'd like it or not yeah
the good news is if the good news is for
like here's Stan and you're like I like
Stan here's Stan Charlie and Sally and
you meet them and you're like I like
Stan and you literally if you texted me
like yo I can't do this at the first day
or if you did it for a week and be like
I can't do this or if you did it for 30
days and be like I can't do this it's
all the same or you'll be like I can do
it like it's really it's I'm really
agnostic to it I think you should
consider it because it does put you in
the best position to succeed for what
you want I'll tell you what I think
where my resistance comes from is having
stuff like that and not having it be
converted
like not having an a player editing it I
got that so if I had that I think it'd
be a lot more exciting to me because my
actual life like first you said to me
you're fit
it's not an accident like my life I've
heard is inspiring
and I want to share that and I built
that over decades you know like
and so there's a lot of people you're
preaching there's a lot to share okay
you know like I was selling wine and was
like I need to share
like I I understand how it happens I
lived it I think the
the genre that he's walking into which
is a modern a really modern
the modern version of spirituality is
really neat because I think what what I
sense is it's similar to what happened
with Fitness
in the 70s and 80s was was much smaller
like you'd be stunned what people wrote
about going to the gym in the 70s like
it's a little culty it doesn't mean
anything like who gives up like now it's
like we don't like he's growing up in a
way like that just like showering like
having an exercise regimen of some sorts
is just like the most normal thing
whereas I'm old enough to know like
nobody thought like that except like the
goals gyms dudes now and so I think
today
even the last five years the concept of
being spiritual
like the breathing the bats the mental
health like all of this
you know five years ago I mean I've been
making content long enough to know like
I was touching on it without even
realizing I was touching on it and it
mattered
now it's like at the Forefront and I
think the appetite for it we haven't
even begun to fill so when I when I hear
what he wants to do there's not enough
supply for the demand and especially on
the male front
right
and you know I think Mike has more we
have like him and I share something
though mine comes across more aggressive
than his does it is in nature
a more like warm
entry point to it you know it's not like
you know something it comes from a
really powerful place like when you talk
about the music is the foundation in
this all spirituality sometimes
spirituality for the sake of
spirituality can get a little knows but
as a part of a much larger ecosystem of
you as a creative musician you know like
then it'd be I I think it goes very
relatable because everyone has multi
everyone's multi-hyphenated now right
whereas like the old Gold's Gym it's
like well that's what I did I lift I'm a
lifter now it's like people do that
because everyone's a renaissance man
Spurs whatever else is going on
again
I lived it man I was born
just kind of a shy depressed Jewish kid
from the suburbs and I looked like my
real life
is bigger than my dreams were
and like that I I came and explained
that
and so how did that happen well like
I'm not just a dude sitting behind the
mic like you know try doing this like
dude I I put my life on the line
like I've almost died of Mount Everest
and I'm the guy that almost died and
kept going and got this like so
I just got something to share you know
and it's deep and it's like
I look at my socials now and it's like
it's one color
but in this I feel like this longer
format I I share a lot more 100 I'm
excited that's exactly let me ask you
please a question there's someone be
respectful of your time
uh
I
when I think about building the team
around me I think about hiring a
president yep who's like with me
compliments me knows how to sell knows
how to Market knows how to build the
team my recommendation is go with more
of a sid of a creative
lead so what are the metrics you look
for in that creative director
what are their kpis
the measure the things that you're
measuring is growth of consumption of
your content not follow count but growth
of actual consumption
views
qualitative feedback and honestly your
subjective opinion of if you're feeling
that you're growing do you know how I
judged it
yeah when I went to the airport it felt
like more people were saying what's up
that was it that's how I judged it
okay and can you help me find that in
person oh that's the that's the main
reason you're here the main reason like
I could have said this to you over Zoom
I want a bunch of people to feel you and
then we'll all debate of like who's out
there yeah God bless you we'll talk soon
enjoy the rest of this meeting
[Music]
thank you